ranga yogeshwar ist bei uns
wissenschaftsjournalist physiker und
moderator ranga über manche ideen und
manche empfehlungen der experten hat
sich die politik gestern tatsächlich
hinweggesetzt
das was da jetzt auf dem tisch liegt mal
unabhängig davon wie hart erkämpft und
erstritten wurde was da jetzt auf dem
tisch liegt ist in ihren augen ok und
alltagstauglich ja und ich glaube was
ganz entscheidend ist ist wenn man genau
zugehört hat es hat ein wandel
stattgefunden
es war noch ein paar tage vorher so dass
ein großteil auch der politischen
vertreter auch natürlich der bürger das
gefühl hatte okay wir haben vielleicht
einen ein frühjahr ja was nicht so tolle
ist ostern aber danach wird alles gut
ich glaube jetzt ist wirklich vielen
klar geworden dass hier ist nicht nur
kurz sind um das hier wird etwas sein
und wir reden jetzt wirklich ende des
jahres vielleicht sogar ins nächste jahr
rein
das zweite ist dass bei all den zahlen
und das hat mich sehr freut wirklich
gestern klar wurde
da hat man einiges verstanden also
plötzlich war die reproduktionsrate als
ein entscheidender faktor im fokus genau
das ist im grunde nur das
steuerungselement denn was man sich klar
machen muss ist wir haben eine situation
wenn man das mal so bildhaft beschreiben
würde
es ist wie ein völlig durchgedreht das
auto bei dem ich das gaspedal nur ein
bisschen drücken und schon beschleunigt
es wie verrückt und ich habe noch das
problem dass sogar mein tachometer
verzögert an zeigt das heißt wir fahren
hier in einer situation die extrem
schwer zu steuern ist und das ist der
grund warum man zumindest
wissenschaftlich wissen muss es gibt ein
profi der uns etwas erlaubt und noch
sind vier und das war das was gestern
gesagt wurde wirklich an der grenze zu
etwas was immer noch sehr schnell ganz
anders werden kann
ein kleines zeitfenster christian
thorsten ist bei uns der chefideologe
der charité hier in
berlin herr droste neigen mensch steckt
momentan ungefähr einen menschen an
diese berühmte reproduktions faktor den
die bundeskanzlerin
da erklärt hat wird wahrscheinlich
unwort des jahres oder auch wort des
jahres weiß man noch nicht würden sie
sagen das ist nachvollziehbar und
richtig sich jetzt vollständig auf
diesen reproduktions faktor zu
konzentrieren und hat die
bundeskanzlerin das richtig erklären das
hat sich natürlich richtig erklärt
produktionszahl was was man
interessanterweise daran auch sieht ist
die unterschiedlichkeit zwischen den
bundesländern und die möglichkeit dann
auch lokal vielleicht zu steuern wir
müssen da vielleicht noch ein bisschen
besser werden aber wir sind schon nicht
so schlecht im berichten über diese zahl
man sieht dass zum beispiel in hongkong
wirklich tagesaktuell also da werden
kann jeder in der bevölkerung die sich
jeden tag anschauen wie gerade die tiere
produktionszahl ist wir müssen noch ein
bisschen mehr in die richtung komme aber
das geht schon ganz gut in die richtige
richtung und ich glaube dieses prinzip
ist nicht schlecht dass man da auch eben
noch mal an einem anderen wert als nur
an dieser reinen kumulativen fallzahl
sieht wie die bundesländer
unterschiedlich sind und man wird da
auch dann sehen ich weiß gar nicht ob
ich das bewerten sollen aber ich sagen
soll leider oder zum glück keine ahnung
aber man wird sehen dass sich die
bundesländer dennoch angleichen
ok also da ist mecklenburg vorpommern
und sachsen anhalt nicht bei diesen
jetzt noch sehr positiven zahlen bleiben
wird ist dass wir zwangsläufig sich
verwischen diese unterschiede und es
wird wird auch andere unterschiede geben
andere entwicklungen und die darf man
jetzt im moment nicht außer acht lassen
es ist nicht egal ob ein 30-jähriger den
nächsten 30 jährigen infiziert oder ein
70-jähriger den nächsten 70 jährigen und
weil weil der abfall sterblichkeit da in
diesen altersgruppen viel höher ist und
auch da ist es so dass das was
eingetragen wurde in die deutsche
bevölkerung erst mal in der jüngeren
erwachsenen altersgruppen stattfand das
liegt nicht nur an den skifahrern aber
auch und auch da werden sich die
unterschiede verwischen das heißt wir
werden bei gleicher fallzahl bei
gleicher infektions tätigkeit dennoch
ein abrutschen auch in die älteren
altersgruppen kriegen und das hat jetzt
nichts mit zb seniorenwohnheim zu tun wo
es ausbrüche geben wird
die noch dazu kommen sondern einfach
auch das natürlicher verwischung effekt
und das wird natürlich dazu führen dass
schon auch nochmal schwerere fälle
gesehen werden also unsere wie andere
länder jahr finden
beneidenswert niedrige sterblichkeit die
wir in deutschland haben die wird nicht
immer so bleiben
ist das eis so dünn wie beschrieben also
für die nächsten drei wochen gucken wir
jetzt erstmal noch es bleibt ein gros
der maßnahmen bestehen und kann man dann
ab dem vierten fünften auf der basis
welcher erfolge eigentlich über weitere
lockerungen nachdenken wie dann ist das
als auf dem gerät na ja die zeit bis zum
es ist natürlich nicht lang also da kann
man jetzt vielleicht noch nicht so viel
sehen man sieht vielleicht mal den
effekt des osterwochenendes ob da
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr eingestreut
wurde aber insgesamt glaube ich nicht
dass das viel ausmachen wird aber es ist
natürlich gut dass da jetzt noch ein
bisschen mehr vorlauf ist für bestimmte
gegen angebote die man da vielleicht der
natur machen kann wenn man sagt wir
wollen da ein bisschen was locker und
dann wollen wir da vielleicht aber mehr
ins detail gehen zum beispiel über ein
elektronisches fall verfolgungs system
das wie ich finde wirklich hoffnung
macht für die allernächste zeit also als
direkte maßnahme abseits von träumen von
von impfstoffen und medikamenten klar
also wir haben eigentlich immer noch
zwei ganz wichtige konditionen die auch
alle experten immer nennen das ist zum
einen die substantiellen tests also wie
substanziell sind unsere daten und zum
zweiten können wir erleichtern zu
präzisen infektionsketten zu kommen so
und auf der basis all dieser dinge die
wir auch nachher nochmal ein bisschen
ausführlicher erklären und besprechen
werden
herr lindner die frage jetzt sollen also
kleinere geschäfte öffnen dürfen das ist
eine der maßnahmen von gestern eine der
lockerungen von gestern bis 600
quadratmeter ist gesagt einzelhandel 600
entschuldigung weshalb 806 oder 800
quadratmeter sind gesagt kleinere
geschäfte wie viele große haben sich
schon bei ihnen beklagt darüber dass sie
das eigentlich viel besser können
hier gehen die maßnahmen liefern leisten
das sagen die verbände ich spreche er
mit den kleineren mittelständlern den
inhabergeführten betrieben die sich
melden
gerade heute eine junge frau die sich
letztes jahr selbstständig gemacht hat
mit einem café und die eine klage
geführt hat über ihre situation die
nicht auch sehr betroffen gemacht hat
und wo ich feststellen kann
gesundheitliche risiken gibt es nicht
nur aufgrund von viren gesundheitliche
risiken kommen auch aus der seele wenn
menschen nämlich angst um ihre existenz
haben die einsatzzeit nach aufgreifen
wir sprechen über lockerungen oder exit
und da könnte bisweilen der eindruck
entstehen es gebe die absicht jetzt im
mai oder juni in den status
zurückzukommen den wir im februar hatten
lockerung also dann geht es wieder
zurück wie das leben davor war davor
warne ich sondern was wir erreichen
müssen ist dass wir ein leben in der
gesellschaft übrigens auch in der
wirtschaft erreichen mit corona
vielleicht noch viele monate ich habe
eine harvard studie gelesen die bis zum
jahr 2022 geht eine infektionsgeschehen
vermuten sondern dass in den status wie
jetzt weitermachen
und deshalb muss die debatte doch da
hingehen auch mit der versammelten
expertise von virologen und anderen
wie können wir die reproduktionsrate
unter 1 halten den indikator akzeptiere
ich aber wie können wir gleichzeitig
intelligenter auch leben ermöglichen
dann mache ich ein paar vorschläge also
nicht ein geschäft einfach öffnen die im
februar aber ob es jetzt ein großer
laden ist möbelhaus oder ein kleiner
laden das ist doch nicht entscheidend
für die infektionsgefahr sondern nur
wird beschränkt die zahl der menschen
pro quadratmeter fläche gibt es
desinfektions möglichkeiten schon beim
eintreten werden die menschen im service
regelmäßig getestet werden dass
schutzmasken verlangt und weiteres mehr
also mit solchen maßnahmen über die wir
sprechen müssen wird ein leben in
freiheit mit gesundheitsschutz vereinbar
und werde dann der letzte gedanke
professor drosten das ansprachen wir
dann mal unsere digitalen defizite
beseitigen mir wird berichtet dass
gesundheitsämter die berichte faxen im
jahr 2020
wo ist denn die vielversprechende corona
app die infektionskette nachvollziehbar
machen soll google und apple arbeiten
zusammen die gehen voran israel macht
fortschritte
in deutschland passiert nichts kein
vorwurf an die regierung im speziellen
aber wir haben größte defizit im bereich
der digitalisierung in unserem land die
dazu führt dass gesundheit und
wirtschaft nicht so geschützt werden
können die fragen geben wir jetzt der
reihe nach weiter so markus söder erste
frage wie ist man gestern in dieser
runde markus söder eigentlich auf die
800 quadratmeter gekommen groß gegen
klein
letztlich ist es auch eine kompromiss-
frage gewesen
ich wäre für weniger gewesen die
kanzlerin übrigens auch einige waren wir
für totale öffnungen an der stelle
ich glaube das ist ein kompromiss weil
es geht nicht nur wie christian lindner
meint um den individuellen betrieb
sondern es geht auch das was man
insgesamt auch an verkehr an bewegung
drumherum anzieht je größer die
einheiten sind darum sind zum beispiel
die ganz großen möbel einrichtungen
schon sehr skeptisch zu bewerten
das sind auch eventveranstaltungen
solche großen unternehmen
da glauben wir dass es schon ein
erhebliches problem werden kann es komme
auf die zeitachsen an in denen wir jetzt
arbeiten wir müssen ja verschiedene
dinge miteinander kombinieren
auf der einen seite des verfahrens
weiter hochfahren des gesundheitssystems
da teile ich die auffassung was die apps
betrifft
das war ein wichtiger beitrag ganz
wichtig das machen nicht noch nicht alle
bundesländer die gesundheitsämter
hochfahren wären wir sind bayern 4000
zusätzliche kräfte ausgestattet um die
gesundheitsämter zu stärken um die
nachverfolgung zu verbessern
650 teams werden gebildet im ganzen land
wir müssen die test 3 deutlich massiv
erhöhen
wir haben zum beispiel bei uns jetzt die
test kapazitäten massiv ausgebaut
auch da die nachverfolgung zu erreichen
also das ist der eine teil unter zweite
teil ist eben bei den geschäften
ich bin da sehr zurückhaltend ich würde
gern den vorsichtigeren weg weitergehen
und da nichts überstürzen das ist jetzt
ein kompromiss wir machen es auch in
bayern
später ich sage das ausdrücklich wir
machen es später obwohl wir parallel
auch in den riesigen finanz- schirm
gespannt haben von allein in 62
milliarden euro für die unternehmen also
wir machen alles sozusagen in einer
komplexen gemeinschaftlichen gebracht
nordrhein westfalen macht die
möbelhäuser auf sagt herr lindner gerade
noch mal eine frage jetzt zum prozedere
das fragt sich jeder herr söder
wie will man organisieren ob diese
ganzen hygienemaßnahmen die hier die
regierung zu einem zu einem kondition
gemacht hat ob die eigentlich auch
wirklich eingehalten werden können also
natürlich muss dafür jetzt jeder vor ort
sorgen und die experten kennen sich da
sehr gut aus aber kontrolliert dass
irgendjemand verfolgt das team
selbstverständlich also das ist ja die
entscheidende frage wir können ja durch
die strategie am ende zu erfolg führen
wenn wir die auflagen die verbunden sind
mit den erleichterungen auch
kontrollieren
so war es ja auch bislang bei
kontaktsperre und bei ausgangs
beschränkungen
das haben manche bundesländer etwas
intensiver gemacht andere etwas etwas
leichter vielleicht gehandhabt aber im
grossen ganzen hat man das in
deutschland einheitlich gemacht so hat
man ja auch gastronomen die doch auf
machen wollten
obwohl es verboten war auch mit
empfindlichen ordnungsmaßnahmen belegt
so würde es da genauso sein dort bin ich
auch feste überzeugung bin sogar ein
bisschen in die richtung wie der
christian lindner
ich habe mir einen masten pflicht schon
vorstellen können jetzt haben wir einen
masten gebaut also einen mund nasen
schutz als gebot entwickelt wenn das
nicht eingehalten wird wir werden das
kontrollieren dann wird es auch eine
verpflichtung gehen und so bin ich
sicher zu kommen damit man überhaupt
eben mehr öffnen kann
vor hoffmann es bleibt wahnsinnig
schwierig und es ist genau die phase in
der es wahrscheinlich noch schwieriger
ist als harte maßnahmen für alle zu
entscheiden
jetzt präzise einige dinge zu lockern
und zwar finden nicht alle also für
weniger was glauben sie wie kann man die
gewinner und die verlierer die es
automatisch geben wird wie kann die
politik das ausgleichen also
beispielsweise auch im handel soll jetzt
amazon besteuert werden soll die
mehrwertsteuer gesenkt werden für den
handel
wie kann man ausgleichen dass es
gewinner und verlierer gibt im moment
glaube ich ist es zunächst einmal ganz
ganz basis eine frage der kommunikation
ich glaube diese 800 quadratmeter sind
unheimlich schlecht kommuniziert werden
worden und es ist nicht klar geworden
was eigentlich der grund ist warum die
grenze da gezogen wird und dass der
zweite punkt ist dass die
ausdifferenzierung noch sehr viel größer
werden muss dass man sich wirklich
überlegen was ich kann verstehen dass
große geschäfte in den innenstädten
nicht geöffnet werden können weil sich
sonst lange schlangen bilden würden die
vielleicht schwierig wäre
aber warum ein möbelhaus am stadtrand
nicht öffnen soll wie ein baumarkt dafür
gibt es überhaupt keine erklärung und
also da erstens ausdifferenzierten
zweitens kommunizieren und ich würde
gerne auch den punkt mit den masken
aufgreifen weil der mir wirklich wichtig
ist und das halt ich fast für das größte
versäumnis dessen was jetzt beschlossen
worden ist dass dort wenn man schon sagt
man will keine pflicht und ich verstehe
dass man vielleicht eine scheu hat zu
sagen wir muten der bevölkerung schon so
viel zu an einschränkungen
und jetzt sollen sie auch noch masken
tragen obwohl ich persönlich dafür wäre
in bestimmten situationen wie
öffentlicher master gehe einkaufen usw
aber dass man mir fehlt was mir wirklich
fehlt ist die leidenschaft in der
empfehlung
ich möchte in derselben weise wie dafür
geworben wird dass die menschen zu hause
bleiben dass sie sich separieren soll
die politik und sollen auch
sympathieträger für diese masken werden
ich möchte frau merkel beim einkaufen im
ulrich schleichwerbung mit einer maske
sehen
so und da fehlt mir wirklich bisher
abgesehen davon ist das alles viel zu
spät gekommen das fehlt mir die
leidenschaft im einsatz für die massen
hätten christian drosten kompliziertes
thema wenn wir mehr lockern wenn wir
mehr menschen in die läden gehen dann
gibt es automatisch natürlich eine
größere gefahr um so sehr verweisen alle
immer auf die hygiene maßnahmen die
jeder ergreifen soll hilft eine masken
pflicht ich denke dass eine masken
pflicht etwas helfen würde
ich kann das nicht quantitativ beziffern
aber es ist klar das hat jetzt auch in
letzter zeit nochmal neue daten gegeben
speziell für coronaviren die es vorher
nicht gab also das sind muss man
wirklich sagen das sind dinge die sind
in der woche vor ostern erschienen das
hat man vorher nicht gewusst
und da muss man einfach dann auch mal
eingestehen und anerkennen dass das auch
möglich ist dass man neue daten bekommt
und nicht sagen
vor einem monat habe ich doch schon
gesagt ich wusste doch alles besser oder
der dieser politiker hat das und das
versäumt das ist ja unsinn man muss
einfach mal vorwärts denken und zum
vorwärts denken gehört jetzt im moment
dazu dass man sich nochmal klar macht es
darf keine markt konkurrenz geben mit
dem medizinischen personal denn da ist
die exposition situation mit masken
nochmal da gehören die masken hin denen
darf man die nicht weg kaufen
und jetzt ist auch die frage wenn ein
verkehrsbetrieb möchte dass künftig
eingehalten wird warum lässt der nicht
textil masken nähen und verkauft die für
1 euro im bus beim ticketverkauf stand
gleich dabei das finde ich total
sinnvoll und ich glaube dass es machbar
das ist aber nur im kleinteiligen
machbar also so nach dem motto wirklich
der verkehrsverbund arbeitet mit dem und
jemand anderes arbeitet damit aber wenn
so etwas möglich wäre
dann käme man aus diesem etwas blöden
dilemma heraus dass man sagt alle müssen
im prinzip masken tragen aber es gibt ja
gar keine und man soll auch nicht dem
medizinischen personal die masken
wegkaufen also ein bisschen pragmatische
haltung wäre schon ganz gut an der so
und nun gibt's dann auch gleich
automatisch neue besorgnisse es heißt
immer wieder dass die viren sich jetzt
doch in der luft halten und nicht zu
schwer sind um sofort runter zu fallen
und werden eben über sogenannte aerosole
übertragen heißt heißt auch dass das
diese 1,5 meter abstand eigentlich
erreichen oder reichen sie nicht müssten
wir eigentlich noch mehr abstand halten
das sind das sind zwei komponenten und
man sollte da auch jetzt vor dieser
rosol sache nicht zu viel angst haben
aber es ist auch ebenso dass da neue
erkenntnisse in letzter zeit aufgetaucht
sind durch aktive nach untersuchen
aktive studien die eben gezeigt haben
dass coronaviren auch in ein ebenso eine
rosol zustand gehen und zwar jetzt in
messbare art und weise nicht so wenig
dass man das dass das alles nur
theoretisch ist und das wird eben auch
eine komponente sein und jetzt muss man
sich das einfach noch einmal klarmachen
wie das funktioniert wenn ich eine
feuchte aussprache habe kann sich jeder
vorstellen wie das ist und da weiß jeder
wenn ich da ein tuch davor habe dann
aufgabe lässt mich das nicht aber es
gibt eine kleinere sorte von tröpfchen
die ja die fliegt ebenso anderthalb
meter weit und dann sind die ganz
schnell zu boden und darum ist diese
abstandsregel genau richtig okay so und
dann gibt es eben unter dieser größe cut
off ist so bei 4 5 mikrometern
da gibt es eine sorte von tröpfchen die
trockner sofort ein in der luft und die
bleibt dann stehen in der luft so und da
kann man natürlich etwas auch machen
nämlich luftzug oder oder auch draußen
sein und da ist zum beispiel wenn wir
dieses wieder an öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln denken wir mal in
asiatischen großstädten war in hongkong
zb da ist in diesem u bahnen die die
gestopft voll sind mit leuten immer ein
luftzug ein erheblicher luftzug dadurch
den ganzen zugegeben und da könnte man
auch mal darüber nachdenken wie man so
etwas hilft die vielen
alltagssituationen ein luftzug gerade im
sommer und dann sind wir markus söder
bei der ganz banalen frage gibt es die
masken pflicht deshalb ich stelle die
frage gibt die masken pflicht deshalb in
deutschland nicht weil wir keine haben
es ist deshalb nur eine empfehlung
geworden gestern
na ja also es gab bundesländer die wir
ziemlich vehement abgelehnt haben das
auch in einer kleinen unterschiede
nordrhein westfalen war man sehr
zurückhaltend bei dem thema wir waren
offen denn ist es ja auch so dass wir
auf der einen seite in der tat haben sie
recht beim medizinischen personal sehr
kämpfen müssen dass wir die versorgung
gewährleisten wir sind jetzt besser
aufgestellt hat sich alle mühe gegeben
auf einem international schwierigen
markt aber auch einem heimischen jetzt
endlich die produktionskapazitäten
zusammenzuspannen deswegen ist es dem
medizinischen personal vorhanden aber
die sogenannten community was da
entsteht auch für chance ich bekomme
masken zugeschickt in unterschiedlicher
haltung hervorragende da da gibt so
tolle ideen anderer an modischen sachen
die es jetzt alles gibt ja natürlich und
es wird auch gehen deswegen bin ich auch
haben wir auch gesagt das gehört zur
hygienemaßnahme dazu ihr professor
thorsten ist völlig zu recht hat dass
das unternehmen das muss im öpnv dass
man es da auch als als soll vorschrift
auch macht und ich bin auch ganz sicher
das wird es entsprechend kommen er es
ist nicht so dass da alle gezögert am
frau schwesig beispielsweise nicht sind
da die protagonisten gewesen
andere haben gesagt es braucht es nicht
aber manches dauert auch ein bisschen
weil es ja auch so ist wenn ich das
sagen darf
so wie es auch die beiden
wissenschaftler gesagt haben wie
entwickeln uns ja auch täglich weiter
manche empfehlungen zu beginn werden
über neues wissen über die über das
virus im weiterentwickelt so ist an der
stelle auch ich glaube dass jeder das
maximale an idee an einsatz bringt um
dieser krise herr zu werden und insofern
trotzdem die frage
ranga yogeshwar hat die politik die zeit
die ja jetzt schon vergangen ist also
die vier wochen jetzt hinter uns fünf
wochen in manchen regionen die waren
hart hat die politik diese zeit gut
genutzt teilweise vielleicht ja aber
teilweise finden die ich auch nicht wie
man wenn man diese diskussion verfolgt
dann reden wir eigentlich über aspekte
und das waren die register die man auch
im mittelalter hatte also garantien
kontakt minimierung masken oder masken
wurden auch im zeitalter der pes
thematisiert aber wir leben im jahr 2020
wir leben in einer zeit bei der wir eine
völlig neue qualität von
informationsverarbeitung haben in einer
zeit wo wir intelligent und schnell
sein könnten und ich bedauere dass wir
diese register die viel effektiver sind
im kampf gegen dieses virus als jetzt
masken pflicht ja oder nein überhaupt
nicht genug nutzen also das fängt ganz
einfach an es fängt an schon bei dem
alltag ja wenn menschen getestet werden
wenn man wirklich mal mit medizinern
wenn man mit ich habe mit meiner
weichheit gesprochen sie leitet hier in
berlin dass das große labor christian
drosten ja von der charité iss angedockt
und andere
und die sagt ganz klar wir haben die
situation bei der immer noch zum
beispiel faxe an gesundheitsämter gehen
bei denen menschen getestet werden und
sie wissen nicht wo es hingeht und siehe
da da hat man jetzt eine initiative
geschafft gemeinsam mit ada das ist eine
software company hier in berlin
und jetzt geht es darum dass wenn ein
patient da ist dass er sein smartphone
mitnimmt und so ähnlich wie bei der
paketzustellung danach auch verfolgen
kann gut wo bin ich dran und er wird
auch informiert also das ist was ganz
einfaches und natürlich die app nach wie
vor die hessen etwas so zentral reden
wir genau darüber
wir sind immer wieder bei der großen
frage wie kommen wir zu substantielleren
daten und es ist jetzt von allen
angesprochen und jetzt fragen wir mal
sind das begründete hoffnungen die auf
dem smartphone liegen und wie weit sind
wir damit
mit einer app und aktivierter
bluetooth-funktion willmann
infektionsketten verfolgen und kappen
sowie bereits erfolgreich in südkorea
und singapur für deutschland strebt das
rk ii aber eine abgespeckte und strickt
anonyme variante an
kommen sich menschen näher erkennen sich
die handys und tauschen anonyme
identifikationsnummern aus wird dann ein
nutzer positiv auf kurve 19 getestet
löst das einen alarm aus alle app nutzer
die intensiven kontakt mit der
infizierten person hatten werden über
handy gewarnt dass alles rettet in
deutschland münchen leben und dass es
eins von vielen werkzeugen in berlin
simulierten bundeswehrsoldaten die app
nutzung ziel eine rasche
massentauglichkeit noch aber hat das
federführende frauenhofer institut
keinen starttermin bekannt gegeben
rang hat zwei fragen wie lange wird es
noch dauern und ist der erfolg der
südostasiatische dadurch zu erklären
dass sie viel disziplinierter sind und
dass sie auf unseren datenschutz zweifel
zuerst einmal fangen wir mal mit den
datenschutz an also ich bin glaube ich
wirklich einer der sich auch in der
vergangenheit sehr engagiert für
datenschutz ausgespart einen preis
bekommen
aber ich glaube wir stehen heute ein
bisschen da wie die feuerwehr die ein
brand löscht
und wenn die feuerwehr plötzlich
vorgeschrieben bekommt dass der schlauch
aber nur sohn so dünn sein darf und
nicht so viel wasser da durchgeht wäre
das absurden dass die situation die ich
zumindest heute erlebe also wir werden
bürgerrechte auf der einen seite
weggezogen und auf der anderen seite
nutzen wir nicht das potenzial das wir
nutzen könnten
wenn man sich die apps anschaut ich habe
einen prototypen der ist vom max planck
institut heute so wird morgen
freigeschaltet wo ist darum geht klüger
zu sein also es geht nicht nur darum mit
einer app zu registrieren war ich nun in
der nähe eines infizierten sondern daten
zb zu erheben das heißt wenn menschen
jeden tag sagen wie sind meine symptome
also fühle ich mich gut oder schlecht
dann sahen lediglich diese daten und
sammeln übersetzer sie über die zeit was
sind die vorteile der erste vorteil ist
dass ich zuerst einmal erkennen gibt es
typische muster auch klarste rungen die
möglicherweise darauf sprechen und diese
person wird möglicherweise an corona
erkranken der sollte besser getestet
werden das zweite ist wir haben die
große chance damit sehr viel früher im
grunde genommen leute zu wahren es gibt
wenn man sich zum beispiel die
wissenschaftlichen oxford anschaut sogar
ferretti der einfach mal gezeigt hat was
der unterschied ist wenn man schnell ist
also ich möchte nicht eine app haben die
wartet bis am ende das fax vom
gesundheitsamt kommt sondern die vorher
aktiv wird damit auch die art und weise
eine infektion zeige drückt und der
dritte aspekt für mich ist
vielleicht ein globaler wir reden hier
von einer globalen krise in deutschland
sind für medizinisch gut aufgestellt was
machen eigentlich ärmere länder in
vielen ärmeren ländern gibt es
smartphones und so eine app wäre
zumindest eine chance auch den ländern
zu helfen also ich sage da müssen wir
vollgas reingehe volldampf wohnt die
rettung also in der westentasche
christian nennen dass zumindest ein teil
der lösung wir werden nicht jetzt alles
mit digitalen instrumenten bewältigen
können was mit dem virus zusammenhängt
aber wir müssen eben alle intelligenten
möglichkeiten nutzen um für
unterstreicht das nochmal über lange
zeit mit dieser pandemie leben zu können
und leben heißt eben auch sich bewegen
können dass die wirtschaft funktioniert
das im bildungsbereich ist nicht allzu
viele verlierer gibt aus der situation
zwei gedanken zu dem was ranga yogeshwar
gesagt hat der erste ist ich weiß dass
es anders gemeint ist dennoch in dieser
gegenwart wichtig das zu unterstreichen
viele sind wegen des edlen zwecks des
gesundheitsschutzes momentan sehr
schnell dabei fragen der gewaltenteilung
der grundrechte unserer verfassung so zu
relativieren
wie gesagt ich spreche ich nicht
persönlich an ich halte das für
gefährlich
das zeigt ja wenn man nur einen guten
zweck hat ist man schnell bereit auch
bestimmte garantien für den einzelnen
aufzugeben und das zweite ist ich glaube
wir müssen gar nicht am datenschutz
schrauben sondern unser datenschutz
würde absolut erlauben dass wir digitale
möglichkeiten nutzen um erstens
infektionsketten erkennbar zu machen
das ist keine raketenwissenschaft warum
gibt es diese app bei uns nicht aus der
start up community erreichen nicht ganz
liebe beschwerden von von co.don
ingenieuren die da gerne helfen wollten
die sorgen finden keinen ansprechpartner
werden abgewimmelt
und das zweite ist ich hätte gerne eine
app in der ich meine herzfrequenz über
über meine sportuhr und meinetwegen
meine körpertemperatur und eingeben kann
und dann wird mein gesundheits geschehen
für mich dargestellt und möglicherweise
gibt es eine warnung achtung hier hat
sich etwas verändert in der letzten zeit
lass dich bitte testen
und da wäre ich auch bereit diese daten
anonym zu teilen damit insgesamt in der
bevölkerung geschaut werden kann welche
die künstliche intelligenz vielleicht ja
welche korrelationen gibt es warum haben
wir das alles nicht im jahr 2020 in
deutschland meine antwort weil leider
wir innerhalb der regierungen und der
verwaltungen an vielen stellen keine
zentrale koordination von
digitalisierungs aufgaben haben und
genau auch ganz konkret in dieser
hinsicht glauben sie frau hofft man dass
diese app freiwillig bleiben wird oder
wird es einen sozialen druck geben die
zu nutzen und will ist meist der spiegel
waren wir endlich die app haben das weiß
ich auch nicht aber ich gehe ich gehe
davon aus dass es freiwillig bleiben
wird ich glaube das ist überzeugend und
letztlich mit unserer gesellschaftlichen
und politischen kultur am besten zu
vereinbaren und ich gehe aber auch davon
aus das ist eine hohe akzeptanz haben
dass sehr viele leute das nutzen werden
und dass es deshalb auch nicht nötig
sein wird das zur verpflichtung zu
machen und ich teile nicht so ganz was
der länder sagt dass wir jetzt in
deutschland und urbane gefahr haben dass
aus diesen notfallmaßnahmen eine gefahr
für eine demokratie oder freiheitsrechte
entsteht aber wir sehen ja in anderen
ländern dass das durchaus der fall ist
auch in europa in polen und ungarn aber
jetzt auch in den usa
also muss auch zusammenbleiben
professor torsten sind die hoffnungen
auf dieser app begründet und berechtigt
dann nicken sie sie haben es auch schon
gesagt ist nicht in der nächste logische
schritt das dann im nachhinein natürlich
eine infrastruktur funktionieren muss
dann müssen die gesundheitsämter die
gerade noch die faxe geschickt haben ja
in der lage sein all die gemeldeten
daten zu verarbeiten und gegebenenfalls
all den roten karten die manche bürger
da bekommen haben auch nachzugeben ist
die da diese im vorjahr so schaffen die
das ich denke es wird eine
einführungsphase geben müssen die eine
kombination ist aus der nutzung von
solchen elektronischen hilfen und dann
aber auch ein faktor mensch der auch in
dem gesundheitsamt
angesiedelt ist und vielleicht auch noch
an anderen stellen an bestimmte
schnittstellen wo sie vielleicht auch
noch nicht so leicht ist solche
informationen weiterzugeben und daraus
auch handlungen hervor gehen zu lassen
da muss man natürlich mit einer gewissen
workforce nie jetzt also ganz schnell
auch eingestellt wird in einigen
gesundheitsämtern komplementär arbeiten
also es wird sicherlich eine phase geben
wo es beides gibt und wo man dann so
einzelne aspekte dann an solche
elektronischen ansätze über händigt
markus söder weiß münchen weiß der
ministerpräsident von bayern wann
deutschland diese app hat ja ich hoffe
wir haben lange überlegt machen eine
nationale app machen wir regionale aber
ich teile die auffassung dass wir eine
nationale dazu brauchen allerdings
möchte ich auch sagen ich glaube das ist
machbar nicht habe doch keine sorge dass
man da jetzt irgend welche grundrechte
einschränken muss ich bin der festen
überzeugung dass es freiwillig gut
funktioniert wie übrigens alle maßnahmen
ja fast täglich überprüft werden von den
gerichten von den verfassungsgerichtshof
in den ländern bei uns vom
bundesverfassungsgericht und wir überall
das jeweilige grüne licht bekommen haben
dass diese phasenweise entscheidung
richtig war weil ich möchte ich schon
aussagen
es kommt so ein bisschen bei dieser app
debatte heraus dass unsere
gesundheitsämter von vorgestern sind
dass die halle sei nicht schwanger
wurden anfangs sitzen würden
ja ich möchte aber alle meine lanze
dafür brechen ich finde dabei zu viel
geleistet und das ist uns besser geht
als anderswo
das hat schon mit mit mit hervorragenden
ideen in der wissenschaft zu tun
das hat auch was mit dem
gesundheitssystem zu tun das ja gerne
auch beklagt wird und immer gerne
kritisiert wird das hat aber auch was
damit zu tun dass der öffentliche
gesundheitsdienst noch viel viel besser
funktioniert als in allen anderen
ländern und natürlich kann man mehr
machen und wir werden auch mehr machen
wir jetzt ganz besonders man aber alle
bundesländer aber auch immer an der
stelle ein dankeschön an diejenigen die
auch mit so einer situation noch nie
konfrontiert waren
und in dieser zeit echt tolle arbeit
leisten gemessen an dankeschön wenn ich
das sagen darf teil das an franke alle
inhaber sollte es nicht bleiben sondern
diejenigen die jetzt mit viel engagement
dabei sind organisationsdefizite
auszugleichen
den müssen wir doch zu sorgen dass
zukünftig die besten materialien zur
verfügung stehen ich zum beispiel habe
über lange zeit nicht verstehen können
dass menschen in der altenpflege
alleingelassen werden
die schutzausrüstung haben die machen
trotzdem natürlich ihren job und da sind
wir zu großer dankbarkeit verpflichtet
wir in der politik egal wo wir
verantwortung tragen haben dann aber
auch die politische moralische
verpflichtung dafür zu sorgen dass alle
mit dem besten verfügbaren material der
besten technik ausgestattet werden und
das so hier in bayern und in nordrhein
sind wir noch nicht da wo wir sein
wollen also da wir wollen und müssen
ganz rasch noch über die schulen reden
nordrhein-westfalen will die besonders
schnell öffnen sie nicht glauben sie
dass mit auch da eine differenzierung
mal freundlich gesagt zwischen den
bundesländern tatsächlich auch soziale
unterschiede bei den kindern einfach
wachsen werden in der krise also die
gefahr besteht natürlich weil man
eigentlich sagen muss die lehrerverbände
haben ausdrücklich vor so einem
kaltstart nach den ferien gewand
ausdrücklich deswegen haben wir auch
ganz bewusst gesagt weil wir mit den
lehrerinnen und lehrern bis zusammen
machen wollten und nicht gegen oder ohne
sie starten wir zeitversetzt starten wir
erst mit den prüfungen da waren sich
eigentlich alle länder einig und dann
erst in bestimmten phasen die
kultusminister müssen ja auch vorschläge
machen was dabei jederzeit machbar ist
mit zeitversetzt nur bestimmte
klassenzimmer nutzen nur die hälfte an
klassen beispielsweise keine klassischen
pausen situation auf kernfächer
reduzierte unterricht wir waren in
bayern zum beispiel auch klar machen
dass wir kein sitzenbleiben wegen corona
wollen weil es kann nicht sein dass weil
unterricht ausgefallen ist niemand die
chance bekommt sich vielleicht doch noch
auf den letzten metern in das neue
schuljahr zu kämpfen
also wir müssen da sehr kreativ und
innovativ sein aber wir haben zum
beispiel gemerkt dass mit dem ersten
schritt der schulen es eine deutliche
reduktion der infektionszahlen gegeben
hat und dass sie muss man das sehr
vorsichtig machen
für uns geht jetzt das sehr parallel
zwischen auf der einen seite ganz
langsam in den schulen zu beginnen
mit pädagogischen konzepten mit dem
weiteren ausbau des home school links
und parallel dazu die notfallbetreuung
gerade für grundschulen und für geht das
deutlich auszubauen bei uns beispiele
es ist so dass viele die plätze die wir
zur verfügung gestellt haben noch gar
nicht so genutzt haben insofern bauen
wird das was da ist sogar noch aus weil
wir tatsächlich den eltern eine
möglichkeit geben wollen
auch beruf und auch die kinder erzählt
so gut wie möglich zu machen aber sie
haben recht wir müssen da noch
nacharbeiten damit die sozialen
unterschiede an der stelle nicht zu groß
werden
deswegen werden wir auch bei dem thema
homeschooling ein stück starke das noch
prägen und präzisieren so und damit sind
wir wieder bei christian lindner
wir alle sind ja auch alltags erfahren
und wissen dass in den schulen nicht mal
seife handtücher und ordentliche
toiletten sind wie soll das
funktionieren sollte ist jetzt alles
immer in bayern
in bayern gibt es natürlich seid
natürlich da sind die alle frisch
gewaschen wie soll das funktionieren
muss jetzt der arme schulleiter
festlegen welche lehrer gesund sind und
welche nicht und wo er seife kaufen kann
ein schritt noch zurück freuen ich
glaube wir haben jetzt hier gerade an
ein beispiel gesehen wo der föderalismus
in deutschland auch differenzierte
antworten erfordert und möglich macht
und da ist es sogar gut wenn man
unterschiedlich aber es ist eben so dass
bayern andere schulferien hat als
nordrhein-westfalen manch ich das heißt
die prüfungen finden zu einem anderen
zeitpunkt statt in passau als in
düsseldorf also ist auch die
herausforderung für die regionale
schulpolitik eine andere
übrigens auch das infektionsgeschehen in
deutschland ist ja stark unterschiedlich
regional geprägt noch wir haben regionen
wenn ich sehe gegenwärtig da sind aber
0,8 andere bei 1,1 1,2 und da wird es
auch in der zukunft gegebenenfalls
einmal notwendig seien maßnahmen
regional zu verschärfen
auch gegenüber dem was wir jetzt an
status quo haben vielleicht noch
schärfer zu werden in hotspots jetzt zu
der frage natürlich müssen die schulen
vorbereitet sein sie brauchen eine
vorbereitungszeit markus söder hat ja
eine reihe von maßnahmen auch zutreffend
aufgezählt schichtbetrieb wie in der
montagehalle größere gruppen und
abstände übrigens auch masken nicht alle
jahrgänge zugleich kernfächer
selbstverständlich ältere lehrkräfte
oder mit vorerkrankungen die können
nicht in den dienst zurückkehren
digitalisierung auch von
bildungsinhalten
aber notwendig ist schon dass es
irgendwann geordnet losgeht wenn ich
weise darauf hin dass die eltern die
ihre kinder betreuen müssen natürlich
nicht zurückkehren können an den
arbeitsplatz über die prüfungsfragen und
bildungsverlierer ist ja auch bereits
gesprochen worden eine der lösungen ist
machen wir so in nordrhein-westfalen ich
sag dir weil wir dort hat die regierung
mit stellen die schulministerin ja auch
meiner partei angehört und der nächsten
woche gibt es die möglichkeit freiwillig
in die schule zu kommen für die
abiturienten wer sich zu hause
vorbereiten will kann das zu hause tun
ansonsten erfolgt das auf freiwilliger
basis in der schule unter beachtung der
gehende maßnahmen zum schutz so das
macht nordrhein westfalen so und bayern
anders ranga yogeshwar festgelegt ist
dass jetzt erst mal die größeren kinder
in die schule sollen weil die
hygienevorschriften besser einhalten
können die leopoldina hat das glatte
gegenteil empfohlen was sagt vater ranga
yogeshwar vier kinder große erwachsene
kinder ist das jetzt die schlauere
maßnahme zu sagen wir fangen man mit den
großen an
ja ich glaube sie ist aus drei gründen
schlauer das erste ist das einfach von
der disziplin her im grunde genommen
dass bei älteren durchaus möglich ist
bei jüngeren nicht
das zweite ist dass es da natürlich auch
junge menschen gibt die an der schwelle
zu einem neuen kapitel stehen sprich
abitur oder einen abschluss machen das
heißt sie müssen natürlich auch die
chance bekommen nicht durch corona
ausgebremst zu werden und ich glaube der
dritte aspekt ist und den werden alle
eltern die kleine kinder haben
nachvollziehen wenn man kleine kinder
hat als eltern die zuerst in die kita
gehen dann wissen alle eltern dass sie
monatelang sozusagen jeden infekt mit
nach hause bringen das sind sozusagen
wunderbaren verteilt stellen für alles
und da ist ehrlich gesagt meine sorge
dass wir aufpassen müssen dass das
wichtigste was wir haben sind kinder
aber dass wir nicht schulen zu super
sprit an machen
von diesem virus und ich mache mir
ehrlich gesagt auch in deutschland
besonders noch gedanken für die lehrer
denn wir haben eine altersverteilung bei
lehrern wenn man sich anschaut wo ein
teil davon tatsächlich eher richtung
risikogruppe tendiert und sich einfach
mal psychologisch vorzustellen wie das
auch für diese älteren menschen ist
jeden tag exponiert zu sein mit vielen
kindern
ja das ist nicht ganz trivial alles ist
kompliziert vor hoffen denn man kann
jetzt natürlich genauso argumentieren
wie die denen es machen es ist super
wichtig gerade die jüngeren kinder und
die kita ist wieder zu öffnen damit die
eltern mit kindern tatsächlich auch
wieder arbeiten können wenn es denn eine
solche lockerung gibt denken sie dass es
aus haltbar ist das jetzt kitas und
kleinere klassen jüngere klassen bis zum
august warten
ich denke ja ich bin derselbe herr
yogeshwar ich glaube wenn wir diese
abwägung haben auf der einen seite
gesundheit dann bildung kinderbetreuung
und die wirtschaft dann sind meiner
ansicht nach gesundheit und wirtschaft
doch die wichtigeren aspekte und eine
längere zeit wo man sich die
kinderbetreuung ja auf teilt auch oft
sehr oft unter zwei partnern
doch eher zumutbar als wir machen ja
eine abwägung zwischen geringere übel
dann ist das glaube ich das geringere
übel wird gern noch zwei punkte machen
das eine ist die der föderalismus also
dass immer wieder dieses negative bild
vom flickenteppich bemüht wird das halte
ich für ganz schädlich und wirklich
falsch sondern wir bräuchten ein
flickenteppich ist gut weil er diese
flexibilität zeigt aber genau das auf
unseren oder sehr genommen und das
andere ist die große angst davor noch
mal maßnahmen wieder rückgängig machen
zu müssen dass die halte ich auch für
falsch und ich etwas muss auch ganz
anders kommuniziert werden es muss
gesagt werden wir wissen es nicht und es
kann sein dass in einigen wochen wir
dinge wieder rückgängig machen müssen
stellen sie sich darauf ein anstatt
jetzt zu sagen wir machen dinge nicht
aus angst weil wir auf keinen fall
jemals etwas wieder zurück nun abstand
das ist kommunikativ falsch und in der
sache falsch wir sind wieder bei der
biologie herr drosten was weiß man wie
sehr schulen eigentlich auch mit
ein auslöser von infektionen sein kann
wie sehr also ausgerechnet schulen egal
welchen alters im grunde in dieser
pandemie in der solche besonders bretter
sein können also dafür sorgen können
dass ist eine infektion gibt bei der
influenza können die das bei dieser
erkrankung wissen wir viel zu wenig das
gehört also hier zu den bereichen wo wir
einfach zu wenig wissen
das geht schon damit los dass wir zu
wenig darüber wissen in welcher form
kinder infiziert sind also die wir
wissen die werden infiziert ganz klar
also da gibt es gute berichte aus china
wir wissen auch die haben weniger
symptome was wir nicht unbedingt wissen
ist ob sie auch in geringerer rate
infiziert werden also ob es pro 100
kindern versus pro 100 erwachsene
vielleicht weniger infektionen gibt und
das in einer einem normalen kontext also
sein familien oder haushalts kontext und
was wir auch nicht wissen ist wie jetzt
die schule an sich dann beitrag zur
amplifikation also selbst wenn kinder
natürlich wenig virus ausscheiden
sollten wenn sie weniger infiziert
werden sollten was wir im moment nicht
wissen
dann sind aber ja in einer schule sehr
viele kinder sehr dicht beieinander auch
über längere zeiten in seiner klasse das
könnte das alles wieder wieder
kompensieren und müssen dann hätte man
eben doch die schulen als wirkliche
motoren der in der virus übertragung in
der gesellschaft wir wissen dass alles
nicht so richtig wie haben sie zitiert
mit dem satz das immer noch ein haupt
spot zu sagen das familiäre umfeld ist
in bezug auf die infektion kein kind
möchte natürlich in anführungsstrichen
schuld daran sein dass sich die eltern
jetzt infizieren und gegebenenfalls auch
daran erkranken
was tut man da klugerweise ja also wir
haben ja hier im moment eine situation
dass kein schulbetrieb ist so dass jetzt
im moment natürlich in der familie vor
allem übertragen wird
aber das kann sich dann natürlich
ernennen also wenn jetzt schulen wieder
geöffnet werden
da muss man wahrscheinlich auch nochmal
differenzieren zwischen älteren kindern
die eigentlich fast erwachsen sind und
dann eben gerade jüngeren kindern auch
kita-kindern da weiß man noch weniger
man weiß nicht ob das hier so ist wie
bei der influenza dass man da eine
überbetonung der infektionsrate in
diesen in diesen altersgruppen hat oder
ob es nicht doch so ist das zum beispiel
bei der merz infektion ist das
anscheinend so dass wirklich kinder
weniger infiziert werden warum auch
immer das so ist ist ein ganz anderer
kulturkreis das spielt sich ja alles vor
allem im mittleren osten ab wir wissen
zu wenig wir müssen darüber mehr
forschung machen
sie haben an vielen stellen und dass man
deshalb ist es auch so schön ihnen
zuzuhören immer wieder deutlich gemacht
wo erkenntnis zugewinne waren was man
alles vorher falsch eingeschätzt hat und
jetzt besser weiß wo haben wir uns noch
getäuscht wissen wir heute zum beispiel
mehr über die letalität wie hoch wird
die wird die sterberate in bezug auf das
virus sein wissen wir mehr über diese
hintergrund immunität von der sie
sprachen dass manche menschen eben
offensichtlich des virus körperlich
verarbeiten und will dann wieder an den
start also es gibt viele solche solche
rätsel also eins haben sie jetzt gerade
angesprochen wir wissen nicht ganz genau
warum das eigentlich so ist dass nicht
alle im haushalt sofort infiziert werden
also es ist gerade eine große haushalt
studie aus china heraus gekommen
das ist schon interessant was man da
sieht dass die die sekundäre rating man
das nennt also die rate von denen die
sich infizieren nachdem ein index fall
in der familie ist ein 1 bekannt
infizierter die ist nicht dreiviertel
oder 80 prozent oder 90 prozent liegt
irgendwo im bereich von 15 prozent warum
ist das so
da sind zufälle dabei da sind sicherlich
jeweils auch maßnahmen dabei dass man
versucht sich voneinander fernzuhalten
aber in so einem haushalts kontext da
fragt man sich eben schon ob nicht doch
eine gewisse bisher unerkannte immunität
auch vorliegt in einem teil der
bevölkerung ritter zum beispiel durch
die erkältungs corona während vermittelt
das lässt sich nur schwer in labor
testen messen
da wird aber sicherlich in nächster zeit
auch neues an daten raus kommen ich kann
dazu gleich sagen selbst wenn da so eine
erkenntnis reifen sollte wird das nicht
dazu führen dass man jetzt im nachhinein
sagt die jetzigen maßnahmen
waren falsch das wird dann eher dazu
führen dass bei diesem dieser jetzigen
strategie diese kurve abzuflachen dann
die kurve nicht ganz so lang ausläuft in
die zeit sondern vorher enden wird
dass das ist so ein effekt also diese
unbekannte immunität bei der legalität
oder da muss man unterscheiden zwischen
fall und infektions sterblichkeit
da gab es ja jetzt dann auch die daten
aus der gangl studie wo gesagt wurde das
ist viel geringer als man bisher dachte
ich glaube auch und professor strecken
auf 1 hendrik schrieb ich bin mit dem
auch in kontakt herr kollege von mir ich
glaube auch dass man da sehr
interessante dinge aus dieser studie
aussehen wird es war natürlich ein
bisschen blöd dass das jetzt so einem
vorläufigen status alles kommuniziert
wurde und ein zwischenergebnis wenn
organisiert so wenig
hintergrundinformationen aber insgesamt
ist das sicherlich eine extrem solide
robuste studie die ich da auch erwarte
also der hendrick hat mir da auch so ein
paar erste einblicke mal gezeigt in die
daten das ist richtig interessant es ist
aber natürlich eine hoch prävalenz
situation also eine ganz ausnahmsweise
aufgetauchte situation sei lange
deutsche songbuch betroffen richtig
genau das haben die die kollegen aus
bonn auch dazu gesagt dass das nicht für
deutschland repräsentativ ist und man
hat da einfach unheimlich viel
infektionsgeschehen und mein gefühl wenn
ich die daten aber anschauen und ich
will da jetzt keine details sagen das
müssen also die kollegen wirklich selber
aufarbeiten und dann eben auch
präsentieren ist aber dass wir da eben
keine überraschung erleben werden was
die infektion sterblichkeit angeht ich
denke die zahl die da rauskommt ist die
zahl mit der wir die ganze zeit schon
arbeiten 0,4 0,5 ja ich hatte mal
einschätzungs bereich von 0 3 bis 0 7
genannt die großen ideologischen
modellierer haben gearbeitet mit zahlen
von 0,7 in einer studie 0,9
das sind jetzt alles nicht sooo riesen
unterschiede also wir werden da keine
keinen ganz erhellenden moment haben und
wir werden auch nicht sehen und das ist
jetzt nicht nur bezogen auf die studie
in gangelt sondern auch das was ich aus
dem kollegenkreis höre auch aus ländern
in europa wo
mehr infektionsgeschehen ist als in
deutschland also zum beispiel in england
in holland aber auch das was ich von
kollegen und von uns selber weiß wenn
man anfängt jetzt antikörper test zu
machen
man findet schon antikörper aber die
liegen eben nicht in einem bereich wo
man sagt wir sind schon halb durch und
wussten dass nun nicht sondern dass das
bewegt sich im niedrig einstelligen
bereich und auch da muss man mit den
tests noch wahnsinnig vorsichtig sagen
sie kommt dazu um sie 15 prozent dieser
in gangelt ermittelt wurden die sind
eben nicht sofort nochmal doppelt
getestet worden auch das werden die
kollegen da jetzt hoffentlich tun aber
man weiß noch nicht hundertprozentig ob
die antikörper eben auch schon präzise
mit dem anti bayern also ich habe das
gefühl dass sie jetzt die bonner
kollegen da jetzt dabei sind aus diesen
diesen anfangs daten jetzt eine sehr
solide studie zu machen das wird extrem
interessant werden
nur eben mit überraschung schlussrunde
bei uns ranga yogeshwar experten
expertin rät das hat der aufmerksame
bürger jetzt auch alles verfolgt
leopoldina und helmholtz institute haben
sich in teilen wirklich widersprochen
das wird zu einer großen verunsicherung
führen
wie kann man die kann der bürger also
gar nicht die politiker entscheiden
sondern wie kann der bürger da
entscheiden was eigentlich richtig ist
und was passt also zunächst muss ich
einfach sagen wir haben tolle experten
also ich habe sehr viel kontakt über
jahre wochen ich meine es ist ein
großartiger experte am tisch der
regelmäßig sein wissen teilt also wie
toll sind die leute da ich glaube was
wir viel stärker tun sollten ist an
einigen stellen das ist in deutschland
vielleicht ein bisschen anders als zum
beispiel in großbritannien ich habe
heute noch gesagt mit einem
wissenschaftler gesprochen aus oxford
und der sagte mir weißt du bei uns ist
es so wir haben einen call und die
besten aktiven wissenschaftler werden
zusammengerufen in deutschland ist es
eher so ein bisschen der präsident ich
will jetzt keinem zu nahe treten
das sind alles leute die ihre meriten
haben
aber wir haben ein riesenpotenzial an
wirklich tollen wissenschaftlern und
zwar nicht nur im bereich virologie oder
epidemiologie sondern eben auch im
bereich künstlicher intelligenz und ich
frage mich einfach die zusammen also
weniger auf die organisation gucken
sondern mehr auf wirklich die ersten
guten wissenschaftlergruppen kann ich
natürlich würde ich mir auch sehr
wünschen
jeder sucht sich so seinen virologen aus
da folglich dem podcast und der bild
zeitung gab es mal eine abstimmung wem
vertraut man jetzt am meisten wie wäre
es wir würden und widersprechen sich
aber teilweise auch die virologen
untereinander wie wäre es wir würden
professor torsten professor strikt
helmholtz krause mit dem ring ja also
wir kommen auch viele inzwischen
erkennen aus den medien
die kommen zusammen und machen
regelmäßig auf wochenbasis eine
gemeinsame empfehlung an die politik und
mein wunsch wäre dann weiter dass zb
bundesregierung und landesregierung
nicht erst in 14 tagen wieder
zusammenkommen sondern angesichts der
enormen grundrechtseingriffe die wir
jetzt haben im grunde wöchentlich
zusammen kommen die gestern und beraten
was kann was muss verändert werden
herr söder ist es in ihren augen eine
gute idee zu sagen jetzt macht
braunschweig eine studie münchen macht
eine studie bonn macht eine studie
wenn und immer versuchen
ministerpräsidenten dann hässlich
formuliert mit ihrem lieblings virologen
auch die eigene linie zu begründen
wenn wir tatsächlich über so einen
bundesweiten expertenrat nachdächten
ja der ist leopoldina ist ja so ein
versuch also ich zunächst einmal glaube
ich dass auch jeder föderalismus hilft
denn es ist ja absurd zu glauben dass
die wissenschaftler in bonn in münchen
in braunschweig in berlin nicht vernetzt
sind also nicht so dass dem luftleeren
raum sind ich freue mich dass seine
vorstellung von wissenschaft
wissenschaft heute ist ja eine vernetzte
struktur der abt mir teams zusammen
nicht irgendein professor in einem labor
sondern die arbeiten der untereinander
und liefern sich jeweils wichtige
erkenntnisse der eine baut auf
andere auf und was er professor thorsten
gesagt das ist doch das entscheidende
wir wissen an vielen stellen noch nicht
das was wir wissen möchten dass wir von
anderen wehren wissen
deswegen ist von woche zu woche
christian ebner es ist nicht so dass
alle vier wochen nur was passiert jede
landesregierung wie der austausch ist
woche für woche
es wird woche für woche gewogen überlegt
was der richtige weg ist aufgrund von
experten rat aber letztlich auch in der
verantwortung zu entscheiden wie diese
abwägung und der verhältnismäßigkeit
stattfindet und meine feste überzeugung
für die tatsache dass wir eigentlich
fast nichts wussten für die tatsache
dass wir uns jede woche weiter
entwickeln müssen hat deutschland die
deutsche politik oder stimmlich alle mit
ein auch die opposition hat insgesamt
einen bislang sehr ordentlichen job
gemacht dafür bewegte ich mich bei allen
bedanken und wir müssen halt jetzt
schauen dass wir durch diese krise
weiter so umsichtig kommen wie wir es
bislang getan haben und zu umsicht
gehört halt auch vorsicht an der stelle
wenn man wenig weiß
dann soll man nicht zu überstürzen ich
würde diesen ratschlag in der ruhe liegt
die kraft eigentlich gemeinschaftlich
fortsetzt frau hofmann
interessanterweise sind die bürger ja
auch sehr vorsichtig es gibt jetzt nicht
nur in bayern herr söder erwartet
vielleicht drauf und dass ich nochmal
die zustimmungswerte der bayern zu
bayerischen landesregierung sage es ist
erstaunlich wie viele menschen in diesem
land gut finden was die regierung gerade
tut wird es dabei bleiben und wie groß
ist die gefahr dass viele eben denken
wir müssen wirklich unterscheiden
zwischen mutig und waghalsig im moment
ist es den stabilen auch die
zustimmungswerte zu den
regierungsparteien das sehen wir ja und
wirklich das einverständnis mit dem was
passiert ich habe auch das gefühl dass
die geduld noch hält aber natürlich ist
es ist das was was langfristig sehr
fragil sein kann und in dem moment wo
die bevölkerung das gefühl hat er wird
uns was zugemutet was eigentlich nicht
mehr angemessen ist wird das hat kann
sich das politisch kann das politisch
sehr gefährlich werden das ist klar wir
müssen hier einen punkt machen ich darf
mich bei den gästen heute ganz herzlich
bedanken danke auch nach münchen zu
markus söder markus lanz macht heute
weiter unter anderem
mit da ist die richtige kamera mit bodo
ramelow und julia klöckner
vielen lieben dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit und die sehen uns wenn
sie mögen kommenden donnerstag wieder
bitte bleiben sie gesund schießt bei
[Musik]